we have jumped over to new york street
now on our studio lot in honor of
tomorrow's thanksgiving day parade in
new york city the show
will go on but it will be unlike any
other in the history of the event
[Music]
that's jimmy fallon rehearsing in the
street and the rockettes dancing in
masks
but for the first time since 1945 the
parade will be a tv-only event
that means no parade route no marchers
and no crowds
i'm not sure how it'll feel you know i
know i'll be on a float so i don't know
if i'll be like waving to nobody
um but it'll you know it's my practice
i'll do it with you let's let's wait
let it snow let it snow let it snow tory
kelly's just one of 17 performers
including
dolly parton and bebe rexha and because
there's no actual parade
performers will all be staying put in
herald square
they're kind of creating like a bubble
for i guess i think i'm one of the few
artists who are actually going to be
there
in person for these events because i
think some people are pre-taping
four broadway musicals including
hamilton are pre-taping their numbers
this year there's 26 floats and 20
balloons but instead of 100 human
handlers per balloon
they will be pulled along by mini
tractors happy holidays
everyone kevin and kelty are hosting the
cbs thanksgiving day celebration
kev chatted with kiki palmer she first
performed at the parade when she was
just
16. i got my new song dream catcher that
i'm going to be performing
what does that mean being on the coach
float coach is classic so what it means
is you're going to be getting fashion
classic
fashion timeless moments that also fit
into the holiday season